we all remember Shaq and Kobe has
arguably the greatest NBA Duo of all
time but remember when they met as
opponents for the first time on
Christmas Day it happened just after the
2003 2004 NBA season where the Lakers
felt short to the Pistons in the NBA
Finals Kobe opted out of his deal and
Shaq demanded a trade Shaq ended up in
Miami and one day later Kobe resigned
with the Lakers yes Kobe was so petty
that he made sure that Shaq was gone
before he decided to stay in La yeah
there was beat and the NBA capitalized
by scheduling their matchup on Christmas
Day Shaq was asked weeks leading up what
he do if Kobe drove into the lane Shaq's
response he's a Corvette I'm a brick
wall in the first play of the game Kobe
got blocked by Shaq but the very next
play Kobe went out Shaq again and hit a
floater over him from there it went back
and forth all night Shaq ended up with
24 points and 11 rebounds but he fouled
out while Kobe finished with a season
High 42 points the game went into OT and
with the Lakers down two with 3.4
seconds left the ball was in Kobe's
hands despite being doubled he got the
shot off but it was no good and Shaq
came out on top in his first ever game
against Kobe